how to use free giveaways to get more  products and get your first sales going  so if you're starting a business right  now the easiest thing to do is give the  services away that you have for free and  you'll be like i'm undervaluing myself  horseshit what you're gaining is  experience because if you have no  customers you're probably not that good  at what you do and so what you should do  is learn for free because people are  going to be spending cost to work with  you they're spending time they're  spending effort they're deploying  resources to do the thing for whatever  services you're providing so you might  as well understand that the value you're  providing is probably low in the  beginning and so you go you learn you  help them you get testimonials you get  referrals from those people and then you  can start charging money because at that  point you'll actually be good and you'll  merit the money that you want to charge